as commentator competitor LC cues are
are definitely just good some of the
hardest things that go through right
because it's alright the best players
cooling pool whatever you want to do it
because they've earned that through
whatever establishment right they're not
here so it's like wow it's the guys I
always lose to all the time once you get
to the top level of any tournament
bracket so in the back of your head you
have that boosted like BAM okay it's
it's still gonna be rough but it's a
little bit easier because of whatever
they can't play but now you have to win
only there is no helmet I could top
eight you know I got fourth I got this
battle I got yeah no you know you get a
pat on the back you get know about old
you get a GG and if you get second
probably like a salty camera shot and
that's it like it's it's so bad so the
fact that my heart is pumping
exceptionally like fast for these guys
and I'm not even playing and these guys
are already widely considered some of
the best players yes right it's it's
insane already that we are here in this
point and speaking of insane we have say
he has his family watching from home oh
man what I'm saying
Casey just show that like everyone knows
kinetic clashes oh this battle yeah and
this when I came into the building right
I wanted to say hi the same but they
were playing an IV to your fear and they
were so locked in that he didn't even
recognize anybody talking to him so it
was in the zone
yeah the Eagles were pumping for
Proposal do something and here they are
on the winter side of top eight trying
to figure it out and again these guys
already making their mark on the term is
showing themselves of course the world
that they are world class IV players but
which one is gonna get into the winner's
final that's what they've been playing
so well and they have so much knowledge
of this character they are so clean but
Casey has just look exceptionally
exceptionally well throughout his
entirety of the tournament right now
saying not to be out that's right that's
the player folks also look like so
caliber players was like all right he's
on the console right we know he's great
but there's like a specific glass
ceiling for him now insane breaks it
it's it's awful so tell you once he gets
open it's to get all over ya and it was
kinetic flashes we talked about it
earlier you know you bought a click
Bechet that he control spacing so well
whether it's near the rig near the wall
he is a master at really controlling
what his opponents does it how they're
trying to look for the ambitious will
punish in that situation but a little
too much on the plate and the thing is
they he obviously is showing that he
really knows the IV much he is able to
control it kind of keeps saying at a
safe distance here all right let's
follow up oh my god he just woke up with
heels I wonder
I would ask think personally but he
can't hear me I wonder how that feels
pulls them inwards goes for the big
sweep here into the Christmas tree
Saints are new to fight back here he
gets the follow-up yeah once again talk
to me let's get back in it better go
over with that stuff who wants nothing
to do it against the launch instead all
five of those things great attack oh you
went for the grab again there and look
at this see look even get on the
scoreboard there's a reversal agent nice
sized set able to close it out that
would have ended it no matter what yeah
I went ahead and just fired up that
trying to figure it out it's Casey jumps
out to a quick two
oh wow did you see that whip footage
that was it save and say no pushing get
out of rage a little bit of extra damage
on that situation great paint and able
to put the brakes on
yeah just gotta throw stuff out you know
her her auto di Brewers that's big she
hit so hard the position so open playing
the games it's the big grab here this is
huge oh he went for it twice Tommy why
of course it's the same look you got to
be ready for it dives under doesn't
quite get points plate to make last
picked up where he left off there's a
brick of tagging all-father than just
brains it oh my god it he went for the
st. ready at the help I love the idea he
saw Ivy get low with and he just stepped
back and said you know what this is not
my time you go ahead and do what you're
doing
and I'll be back when you finish with it
for this one now both players having
that meter here let's see who's able to
pop first who's gonna take the advantage
and who's you know hopefully it'll get
some big damage here oh wow nice evil
you babe
and again kinetic flash looking real
good here the outset of round number
five oh that's big
yeah same through the paint job of like
attacking
well daddy's motion runs up great the
lake yeah I'm watching will cancel
continue with office we're going back
the other way this is huge all sort so
much for you what another opportunity
Christmas tree to tackle some damage and
line up into its summit suffering and
kinetic flash is gonna take Game one
wait a bit wait a minute and again this
is still opening don't forget about me
now I'm more than just biceps all right
boy man what's saying gonna do here
obviously he's gonna stick to his
character too they're going to keep the
stage I mean it could have gone either
way for that that series at the end we
launched but with so many sweep again
the both players have been getting a lot
of mileage others seek especially up
close you do either one you know the
other players wanting to duck oh great
it out come on there's opportunity there
so you're gonna go in there and slide am
not sure what the idea was behind that
but it's dead close again hold the
fragance so much respect for both
players in the sidestep so seen able to
take that round here in match number two
again great escape there
and excellent but it maybe could great
escape indeed oh you got the lethal he
just that was all reactionary in that
situation coming in for the same and
right back-to-back catching the walk
follow-up just out of rage here
Oh put the - a doing that yeah you got
throws I got those two trying to feed
his way back into this one pull-up at a
time but uh not having it and those
sports all right
getting back to the normal order of
things are you with restoring order yeah
as that self came here to throw a wrench
and everything would just his pressure
alone just spacing look at this pushing
back to their to clash memory that's
where he wants to babied ever mind he
doesn't want that
he definitely people tournament where he
just does nothing until you do the thing
has any relationship without the flash
is uh starting to fight back here look
at him he's pushing up again walk
backwards waited for his opponent to
come back okay
the follow-up here able to interrupt
there with the sole charge
oh we try to we put it for that I like
the idea but we out of that range with
the raw log screwed up nice follow-up
attempt to come back here he's gonna
have to do something here this is big
finds an opening follow-up yep points of
that so many times
yes well the follow-up Oh kinetic lash
look yet I get you gotta remember he's
up right now even though sait is
controlling this second match he is up
oh he caught him
gets the grab the follow-up here what's
gonna do watch no goes for the stop
gonna step a little bit how does a lot
of damage but it stops same look even
close it out he does want to tie it up
of course
Oh gets it follow up here it goes to the
crib sweet oops um out of the air here I
like the ideas just ain't ever want to
avoid that seems to be the start though
this could be the start up as well yeah
oh my gosh kinetic glass from the
clutches of tying it up looks too maybe
those new order that has to come maybe
it's it's a different thing is that for
just a leader of the momentum ship
you'll obey
uses the guitars here oh do you try to
catch up doing something dirty I have no
idea but he's gonna capo into the CEO
Lee he would know
fortunately force ain't gonna take
advantage of the situation a couple like
I mean look at that thing just got
straight into combo te that's yeah it's
gonna be really hard I was to identify
she's gonna have to work his way back
it's always of the light bar sorry you
did last round so it should be no
surprise again so just missing it a
little late to the draw saying no launch
it said the sweet picking up Christmas
trees presents what do you want how
about a trip home painting with the big
advantage right now but class has meter
down okay pops the sole charge let's see
how this works out expected that and I'm
not sure the decision on that was same
just going for it
just a TI in between taking the
guarantee on the follow up and save
getting on the floor tying it up at one
game apiece it's gonna get rid of
whatever was hindering his body progress
right and look at that man that man is
yeah is he like he's about to push this
doesn't move it that's 30 Fawcett it
anyways enough I promise you it won't
going to what we're gonna drink some
water
yep it's kind of stay hydrated here we
go here we go this is the final match
between these two and again this battle
of the IV history it's been going back
and forth one moment you think kinetic
lash you're gonna make this big comeback
and then I'm st. out of nowhere just
getting all the hits that he needs all
these fire caliber players from around
the world
alright just outside the range or what
if it it wouldn't hit what oh wait it
was a competitive pressure what it was
and this is gonna hit the walnut it
seems it's gonna follow up here as well
if there's a lethal hit look insane look
insane something just so off about the
beginning of that entire sequence but
right in the lane for st. stop now you
show it off you want a TI to a Plus D
just been activated the third Aybar head
it is read to keep it to the depths of
just same thing he is on he's on another
level right now oh my god
thanks for playing damage oh my god in
the follow-up to it but you know
everything sensei likes to play with his
sword I only pulled my sword out of
Houma papa use a real Oh
bro man mentality coming in from kinetic
flash and that is gonna hurt say fry
let's see I respond spinning the bar or
this round and a waste of soul charge as
phonetic class sizing up at one he had
an even though he had it make a comeback
thing you don't want to give up the
round no man that round was all put over
that situation unblockable followed up
by lethal hit but again saying believing
until the bitter end no matter what
right back at you watch your legs to the
slide but you're not safe
here we go what still in the driver's
seat after six weeks and the run up
sweep are you trying to get with the
graphic nice great gets the counter he
doesn't follow up afterwards here we go
what's he gonna do this is big oh he got
him with all of the hits take off some
of those clothes right quick one round
away KC trying to close the door on
Saints winners runs hope the gentleman
still very much alive regardless of what
happens in this situation but the only
thing he fakes at the inflamed that's it
I saw it comes out and it's very real
however it seen first blood here in
round four and right back capture let me
show you what else like stopping the
momentum that kinetic flash that their
second hit the Christmas tree Auto di
happy holiday got a cancel out the other
one trying to create something out of
nothing
here we go pushes up at the wall again
back to back hey come back to the duct
of that unblockable for save is that one
more toe tap Christmas tree to try to
get the save that amount of air - no way
no way buddy no this will all right 2k
to seal the deal and final game final
round I am so sick of this
what maybe the stuff that has a fan of
the game I couldn't love it anymore
I hope they patch final rounds out of
the next game okay an intense series of
course between both of these players
again the Christmas tree follow-up
blockable the cancel trying to keep that
pressure going on
good ending clash all he's getting it
here's about the fire up that sword and
let it rock once again see no hesitation
no games when it comes to with the scene
all fun and games
wait a minute I don't know what we're
gonna do it looks like we just
continuously overzealous there the
follow up here what you get to do but
kinetic lash has the resources here
let's see be able to bout to come back
here out of the aerial stage oh what a
job between it looks for the Reggie is
that it it's gonna be the symphony sent
me a sweet song of victory as sane
advances to the winner's final
and that's where you want to be you want
to be in that favorable position going
into potentially the grand final so in
the winners finals now he's gonna be
playing extended sets throughout but man
got to give it up both of these players
play such amazing Soulcalibur both of
them seen absolutely can't believe it
hard there you go now right so when
there's losers grant should be three out
of five correct yes at least from what I
know yes but men back and forth I
couldn't tell I mean it brought us back
to form but we were you seen you know
yes couldn't tell who was gonna win
someone was up dominating then all of a
sudden went back